[Music]
leaders in canada
are struggling to come to grips with the
legacy of their predecessors
across the country activists are calling
for the removal of statues
dedicated to men considered forefathers
whose names
are increasingly synonymous with a
legacy of discrimination
and violence against indigenous
communities
oh this is a town in horrible grief
this is a community broken this is a
community
stunned and shattered and grasping for
ways to deal with it and
it's hard for a lot of people to
comprehend this
a week ago the remains of 215 children
were found in an unmarked grave at an
old boarding school
designed to culturally isolate
indigenous children from their families
since then canada has been going through
a public reckoning
215 indigenous kids
were found in an unmarked
mass grave anytime we think about
unmarked mass graves we think about a
distant country where a genocide has
happened
this is not a distant country this is
here
in canada from the 1880s to 1996 an
estimated 150
000 children were taken from their homes
many of them by force
as part of an assimilation program run
by the government and the catholic
church
they were forbidden from speaking their
native languages and subjected to
physical
emotional and sexual abuse
[Music]
in 2015 the truth and reconciliation
commission of canada called the practice
a cultural genocide the recent discovery
of bodies
has prompted calls to search all such
schools for more
unmarked graves where thousands more
children
are thought to be buried certainly no
surprise at all
everybody in the first nations community
knew that there are mass graves
we've been calling it for years we've
been telling the government for years
that there are mass graves in every
single residential school
but they didn't listen to us flags are
at half-mast
until further notice and canadian prime
minister justin trudeau
spent the week recommitting to
reconciliation
saying sorry for the tragedies of the
past is not enough
it's not enough for the children who
died for the families or for the
survivors and communities
only with our actions can we choose a
better path
and that is what our government will
always try to do
on tuesday he kicked off national
indigenous history month
by announcing an investment of 18
billion dollars over five years
to address socioeconomic disparity in
indigenous communities
but critics say successive canadian
governments have been slow to address
ongoing issues of discrimination even
blocking efforts
to uncover and report past atrocities
cases of missing and murdered indigenous
women and girls remain
disproportionately high
and largely unsolved and violence
against indigenous people
also continues critics say that is all
evidence
that indigenous people are among the
most marginalized
in canada zain basravi al-jazeera
very pleased to welcome chief norman
yakulea al jazeera he's the regional
head of the north west territories
for the assembly of first nations he is
also the chief of the
dene nation joining us from yellowknife
canada chief thank you for
your time today it strikes me and we
heard it in that report and i heard it
from a guest
earlier we wouldn't even be having this
conversation
right now a wider conversation about
canada
and its past if this discovery hadn't
been made
and yet people like yourself have been
saying this for years now
in my language i said thank you
my people it's beautiful outside and
certainly you are correct
to the world that we will not have this
discussion
if it wasn't for with a heavy heart i
say for
our children to expose this
reality that's been happening with all
indigenous people
around the world and especially in
canada
and the northwest territories that our
elders
our old ones have been telling us for a
long time
what happened to the students in the
residential schools
in canada and the northwest territories
of their children and their family and
loved ones
who have not come home once they were
forcefully removed to attend a
residential school
that was to civilize the indigenous
people the then a people
and we want to ask for prayers for
people
to pray for us and for people who
suffered this
type of policies
all around the world especially for us
in canada it is the children
who are saving us free the schools
themselves
are a thing of the past the last ones
closed in the mid 1990s i believe but
can you tell our
international audience the ways in which
indigenous people in canada are still
marginalized
today in in 2021
thank you the last residential school
was closed in the newbie
called the groyer hall residential
school which was notorious for
over 20 years of sexual physical abuse
on the young boys by the residential
school
and our girls there and we want to
show that the residential schools
in canada that have been exposed over
130
of them that certainly
it started with the doctrine of
discovery
and came to canada that the talking of
discovery
said that the indigenous people were not
people and that when they came over
it gave the right to the europeans
people in england spain the right to
come on our land without recognizing
respecting
that for thousands and thousands of
years
there were indigenous people living here
with our own societies
our laws our language but that doctrine
is a dangerous document and that the
crown
the king of england and the churches
use that to put their way of thoughts
life upon us and to make us something
we are not and we've been fighting for
that for 153
years with canada chief norman
justin trudeau the prime minister he has
apologized which i'm sure
is welcomed and then he says only with
our actions can we choose a better path
what should those actions from the
canadian government be
first of all let's get to the bottom of
this
tell the truth look we need to sit
and work with indigenous lead to
work on all these residential schools to
see if there are any other
unremained sites to be discovered
let's check all our residential school
sites
in canada and it needs to be led
by the indigenous leaders and the people
governor canada we have tired of your
words
of saying you want to do it for us you
did that
in the residential schools you wanted us
to learn to speak
english write english learn your ways
at the same time forgetting about who we
are as a denny
culture and our values so we say to
canada first of all
support us and we will do our own
investigation we have
doctors lawyers and we have
well-educated chiefs and we have our
elders to guide us
and then to ask the pope to come to meet
with us
indigenous people face to face and talk
with us
you have a role in this and all the
other churches
the anglican church we asked the pope
since 2015
to come and to talk with us and to
apologize
enough is enough we are
people and we ask the pope to give us
that opportunity
to sit and talk with us the pope
of rome and so we have not heard from
him
yet so we're tired of waiting
chief norman jacqueline we really
appreciate your time
to talk about this very important issue
thank you
thank you we asked the world to pray
with the denny and all the indigenous
people in canada
thank you very much for this opportunity
thank you